l a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono file j e oggi siamo tornati
sull'attacco dei giganti episodio 2
trovato il 34esimo cadetti sta
combattendo contro i giganti ma dov'è
quando lo vedi ci penso io amici ma
again è andato giù non è andato giù
chiesto guardi urca vacchia ci ha usato
il fuoco pure lui mi ha fatto malissimo
tra l'altro baby non ce la faccio
[Musica]
drogato maledetto di un gigante mavava
angola stasio eliminazione superiore ma
questo è buttato per terra ma io posso
dare gli ordini anche i miei compagni
non lo faccio mai specie di farmi non
sbatti ho sempre seleziona vai attaccate
attacco lo c'è cosa mi sbatto a fare
posso ordinare i miei compagni di
ucciderlo occhio che c'è quello che si
suicida si suicida
lo vedo che si suicida lo so io ecco lo
ha tirato una testata fortissima tra te
3 porca che mi ha inglobato aiuto amici
vista in meno male che non è il bene
perché se non era veramente una roba
brutta è
aiuto aiuto casacca questo è difficile
cosa c'è di strano non lo fare non lo
fare non lo fare zio credimi credimi non
lo fare almeno non ti sei buttato a
terra malissimo guarda ho previsto una
di quelle figure di kakà che fatti di
solito coi giganti e non è successo
potreste fare qualcosa poi che gli
orbitato intorno senza fare niente
aspetta aspetta non uccidere voglio dire
che cosa fa giganti sui cibi
ciao l'ho preso in faccia agli elevato
poco ma quel poco bastava per ucciderlo
coni mi dai una mano ha intenzione di
cosa state facendo
a voi siete la mia squadra bene c'è un
gigante la dieta lo avete voglia di fare
qualcosa
faccio io web fratello guarda quansi
beau cioè dai lega pro non dovette
orbitare intorno dovete farlo fuori
attacca attaccate fate qualcosa per
l'amor di dio
le faccio io va ha capito sembra mio ex
compagno di classe web mi stava anche in
culo quindi via si è unito alla squadra
quello che aiutato
va bene che sei così utile
stai facendo la cacca papa i signori
frate occhio la donna che è male mi fai
aiutatevi compagni maledetti schifosi
datemi una mano
mi date una squadra che sia in grado di
fare una minima cosa una minima mi fa
non fanno niente mi fanno pena fanno
solo pena non fanno nulla
faccio tutto io porca vacca o invece
normale cioè che ha detto che sta
urlando attorno c'era un muro world cava
che lo schivato per niente o meno male
l'abbia fatta
[Musica]
grazie
sono uno più brutto nell'altro giusta
quando ancora da loro cuoco michael
roma le luci
[Musica]
[Applauso]
così
[Musica]
sotto ai gioielli
[Applauso]
[Musica]
chissà se i miei compagni stanno bene ma
ci vedi non è successo niente
non solo squartati in 15 però dettagli
ok il mondo che vide la ragazza capitolo
1 episodio 3 raga non so se li avete
visti ma c'è gente grossa che sta
arrivando da voi tipo questo che se
qualcuno non lo fa fuori sono cazzi
tieni assicuro al cittadino cittadino
cosa ci fai qua in mezzo alla merda ma
entra in casa maledizione
ok ci provo ma perché devo fare di tutto
io no dove dove occhio la faccio fuori
io perché ci provo
le gambe è andato aiutatemi lag aiutate
non posso fare solo
aiutatemi e vabbè se devo fare tutto io
è un casino prima grana che fastidio
ragazze ne sono troppi se non mi date
una mano un casino ve lo dico si con del
qatar grande marca vacallo difendere i
cittadini è impossibile ve lo giuro
cambia le armi veloce
[Musica]
perché lui è andato però ragazzi
veramente sono mi date una mano al
casinò gesù no no no no no no alla
mangiato l'ha mangiato l'ha mangiato
l'ha mangiato sono scemo ma mi fai
perdere la missione vero tanto né se
roma non solo per non importa quello non
solo caga nessuno fa niente
avrai fatto è morto solo una
sono un cittadino nord va bene va bene
[Musica]
scende si mazzarano ha dato ascolto ai
denti rai
jobs teche cartella ciao madonna che
porta
[Musica]
la cina
asca
[Musica]
l'avete visto il gigante quello che
combatte con le autrici cantiere perché
si è trasformata in gigante quando l'ha
inghiottito l'altro a salve
c'è un gigante di fuori buongiorno posso
vedere la madonna potrebbe farci fuori
da un momento all'altro ma sta qui a
osservarci perché non va bene cosa dici
che non va bene tesoro
ah ok a ufficio a salve ma è una
situazione più di me è fatto di
ossidiana questo posto che non riuscite
a distruggerlo e finita per noi armando
è la fine sembra di sì è infatti era
quello che aspettavo da un bel pezzo
però non era ancora successo
salve
questa la situazione veramente brutta
madame che pu morale
ma se non ci fosse rehn
o no un mondo come quello più duro
no scusate mi no ono casinò chiusi
occorso a grigio rosa siamo fuori da
signora ionio si vedrà tyson michael yo
di chiara pulita giappone però dai seggi
ok come se dovesse essere un mistero per
me chi è questo qua no tanto li faccio
sempre fuori io non è che se c'è lui
cambia la situazione
la tua donna che volte e botte ho visto
ragazzo o li direi che però ci va bene
così è stato fighissimo spero vi sia
piaciuto quello che anche questo secondo
episodio realtà per i giganti quasi lo
ragazzi veramente piace anche ai social
con iscrizione senza rischia di veder ci
vediamo conseguito dai ragazzi
[Musica]